and over a certain age i just feel like  you can't blame your trauma anymore like  it's just i don't know what age that is  but it's just like at some point you got  to be like you know what i think i just  make bad decisions that's too hard for  women to to get to that point i was  literally thinking about that today it's  like we've we've gotten to a point in  society where you can't even talk to a  woman about anything that she disagrees  with or she'll go crazy like she'll lose  her ever-loving mind and then literally  like hit you with all of these attacks  whatever she'll send her friends to you  too  and it's ridiculous like they act like  little children like throwing a  full-blown tantrum at the mall and all  you want to do is slap him in the face  like i'm so sorry to break it to you you  can't you cannot put your trauma on  anyone else sorry  can't do it